what a bringing you a Fox News Alert Fox  can confirm tonight that former  Associate Justice of the Supreme Court  John Paul Stevens has died at the age of  99  he even served on the court for almost  35 years he retired at the age of 90 he  was appointed in 1975 by President  Gerald Ford but later became known as  one of the courts more liberal members  move steadily left over those years as  justices tend to he was succeeded in his  seat by current justice Elena Kagan even  after his retirement into his late 90s  Steven remained Stephens remained active  just last year he wrote an op-ed calling  for the repeal of the Second Amendment  and then attacked Trump Supreme Court  nominee Brett Kavanaugh is unfit to  serve on the Supreme Court he became a  wild-eyed crazed partisan in his final  years unfortunately